We already defined
work in one dimension
is the product of force
times displacement
for a constant force, but
now let's look at a case
where we're applying a force,
f, that is a function of x.
So, our component, f
of x, is a function
of x in the i hat direction.
And one of the simplest
examples of a force like this
is what we call
the spring force.
Now, when we apply this
force to our object--
and let's look at an
object, i, i hat direction,
we'll have an origin.
And this is our plus-x
coordinate system.
When we apply force--
what we want to look at
is because the force is a
function of position-- then
we want to look at
the displacement
over a small amount.
So let's call this the point xj.
And out here, let's refer
to this as xj plus 1.
And what we've
done is we're going
to ask how much work is done
when the force is displaced
from here to there.
And that's what
we'll call delta x.
So now our displacement is
a small displacement x of j
plus 1 minus x of j.
And our work for this small
displacement-- and that's
why we'll indicate
it with a delta-- is
equal to the force,
which is a function of x,
times this displacement.
And so we get f of x times
x of j plus 1 minus x of j.
And what we have
to indicate here
is because the force
is varying, we're
looking at just this
displacement here.
Let's refer to this force
as in the j-th part.
The total work is just the sum
of all these scalar quantities.
Remember, although force is
a vector and displacement
is a vector, the product
of these two quantities
is a scalar.
And so, if we want
the total work,
we have to sum from j goes
from 1 to n of this quantity
f of j dot-- and I'll
put a little j there
to indicate that-- delta xj.
What does this sum mean?
Well imagine that we're making
a series of displacements
all the way out to
a final position,
x final, and we divided
this interval into n pieces.
And so this represents
the little bit
of work done for all
of these displacements.
And that is what we
define to be the work
for a non-constant force.
The issue here is about how
fine we cut this interval in.
We made n individual pieces.
But if we want to
ask ourselves, what
is the limit as n
goes to infinity,
then that's what we
now need to consider.
So what we're doing
is we're making
smaller and smaller and
smaller little displacements.
And we're taking this
sum-- j goes from 1 to n
of x of xj times delta xj.
And this limit of a
sum is by definition
the integral of the
force with respect to dx.
So what we end up with is our
work is the integral of f of x.
It's a function and I'm going to
have an integration variable, x
prime of dx prime,
where x prime is
going from our initial
position to our final position.
And this is now our
definition of work
which generalizes a constant
force to a non-constant force.
Again, let's try to
look at some type
of geometric interpretation.
So if we plotted
f of x versus x.
And now let's
consider a case where
we have some arbitrary force.
So I'm going to just draw the
force as if it were arbitrarily
increasing as a function of x.
And here is our x initial.
And here's our x final.
And again, we would like to
make a geometric interpretation.
Let's consider xj.
And I'll make this very big.
xj plus 1 for the
sake of visualization.
And this value here is f of xj.
And so what we see now is
that little bit of work,
like we had for
a constant force,
can be approximated as the area
underneath the curve for just
this small interval
between xj and xj plus 1.
And if we make this
sum, what we're doing
is we're just taking a
series of approximations
to the area under these curves.
Now you can see,
graphically, that there
is very little error when the
function was nearly constant.
But in this position, where
the function is growing,
this represents
our little error.
However, in the limit,
as n goes to infinity,
we can make that error
go vanishingly small.
So once again, we see, as
a geometric interpretation,
that this is the area under
the curve of the force
versus position
between the points
initial xi and initial--
and the final, x
final, where the
particle is being
displaced from an
initial position
to some final position.
And here we can call our initial
position anywhere we want.
If I write that, this x
initial, to the final position.
And that's our generalization
of the definition of work.